こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
みんなは肌荒れ、肌のカサカサ、肌の乾燥
悩んでないかな？
そう！
僕もね　完全にその悩む一人なんすよ
もうね　見てもらうと分かるんですけども
お肌がボロボロなんですよ
動画だとちょっと分かんないんですけども
俺の肌はもう
わりともうね　ここらへんとかもう　ボロッボロになるレベルで
お肌乾燥した君たちには
こういうね、「ニベアクリーム」っていう
ボディクリームが有効的なんです
天才の僕は考えた
そう！
ここには
ニベアクリームを約100個以上
よく分かんないんですけども
すごい量準備したんで
今日は　この　ニベアクリームを　全部使って
お風呂を作ってみようと思います
そう、書いてあるんですよ
「お出かけ前や洗顔・入浴後のご使用が効果的です。」と
これはね、何を意味してるかというと
入浴中はクリームが肌に塗れない
つまり、入浴後じゃないと塗るタイミングがないんで
１番良いタイミングは入浴中なんです！わかる？
ニベアクリームでお風呂作っちゃえば
入浴中もニベアクリームを浴びることができるので
完璧なパーフェクトバディ（Perfect body）ができるわけなんすよ
だから・・・なるべく買ってみた！
使い方は間違ってないからね
お肌を守るために、そう、使用用途は間違ってないから
そんな多分死ぬこともないと思うんで
というわけで今日は
ニベアクリームを大量に使って
お風呂を作っていこうと思います！
俺の・・・ピーーフェクトッバディ（Perfect Body）のとぅめに
・・・・・・・・・・・・・
では行こう！
よしよしよしよし、行くぞ！
はい！というわけで、今からお風呂にニベアクリームをブチ込んで行きます
一番心配なのは、浴槽が詰まっちゃうと怖いので
ちょっとクリームの様子をまずは見たいんすよね
これで中身のクリームが硬すぎるともう最悪の事態
あっ　あっ、めっちゃいい匂い
ああああああああ
ああ～～～～～～
あっ、まあまあまあ、でも、やっぱ
とりあえず入れていきましょう！
待って
ほんとに？
後輩：うん
あっ、味が
２個目！
これはヤバい、気が引けるわ
これだって、家族が皆で長い期間かけて使うやつを
俺この一瞬で・・・パーにしてるからね
３個目！
４個目！
５個目
６個目！
７個目
８個目
９個目
１１　１２
１３　１４
１５　１５　１６
ﾈｱｱｱｱ
１７！　１８
あっ　待って、ヤバい
やばい！
あっ、やばい
あっあっあっ
１８？
コケた衝撃で全部忘れちゃった
なんて言ったっけ？俺
はじめしゃちょー：１８だよね？たぶん
後輩：１８だね
１８！
１９　２０
２１　２２
２３　２４
２５　２６
２７　２８
２９　３０
３１　３２
３３　３４
３５！
クリームが出していい音じゃないよ・・・
３６　３７
３８　３９
４０　４１
４２　４３
４４　４５
４６　４７
４８　４９
５０　５１
５２　５３
５４　５５
５６　５７
５８　５９
６０　６１
６２　６３
６４　６５
６６　６７
６８　６９
７０　７１
７２　７３
７４　７５
７６　７７
７８　７９
８０　８１
８２　８３
８４　８５
８６　８７
８８　８９
９０！
９１　９3
９4　９5
９６　９６
はじめしゃちょー：くっじゅうきゅう（９９）！
後輩：あっはっは
１００！
はい！　というわけで完成しました～！
はい、というわけで無事
クリーム全部入ったんですけど
これではやっぱもうお風呂になんかったんで
ちょっと、お湯をつけ足して、ニベアクリーム風呂を作っていきまっしょう！
おっけ、おっけ
あぁ、ばん！　えっ？
はじくね・・・
浮くんだけど
後輩：分離してるね～
はじめしゃちょー：やばいね～
ちょっともうちょっと様子見てみましょう
はじめしゃちょー：ふぉう！
後輩：あっ、穴開いた
後輩：ハーゲンダッツ刺さってるよ
後輩：ハーゲンダッツ刺さってる
はじめしゃちょー：どこに？
後輩：頭
はじめしゃちょー：はあ？
ど、ど、どうですかね・・・
こういう感じになております、今
やっぱ、クリーム　肌のボディクリーム　脂なんで
ちょっと水と分離しちゃって浮く状態になっております
じゃあちょっと実際に入ってみようと思います
あっ
これは・・・すごい、クリームと
ぺっ！
ぷっ
クリームと、お、お湯がマッチしてとても気持ち良いですね
あっ、すごい・・・
あっ、普通にでも、いいです
なんか全身がものすげえニベアに包まれてる感で
ちょっともう水はじくぐらいになっておりますね
いや、いいよ　本当に
はい、というわけで　皆さんいかがだったでしょうか
ニベア風呂
肌にはよさそうです
肌がすごいツルツルになったんで
是非あのね、発注ミスとかでニベアクリーム沢山買った時は是非
やってみて下さい
ニベアクリーム是非使ってね！
じゃあな！
やば、完全にガチ